kill every Targaryen
my hands are everyone who isn't
so I did it bring me its panties we take
what is ours
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video today I want to talk
about Vissarion in some of the ways the
undead dragon could possibly be killed I
really don't want to get into the debate
about whether Viserion is a white dragon
or white Walker dragon because I already
gave my opinion on that in my first
video about how to kill Vasari on about
10 minutes after this episode ended I
released a video where I talked about
several different ways I thought this
Aryan could be stopped but the main
reason why I want to talk about this
again is because I am wondering if Jaime
Lannister will try to kill this dragon
we have seen Jaime try to kill a dragon
before so perhaps he tries to do it
again now that the night king has his
own dragon this makes him even more
dangerous than he already was so they're
gonna need to stop vissarion as soon as
possible otherwise things could get very
ugly in the north
we already saw this area knocked down a
giant portion of the magical wall so I
can only assume what he could do to
people running around on the ground
since vissarion is powered by the nine
Kings magic you may be able to kill him
by killing the knight King first just
like beric Dondarrion suggested but we
don't know how true that actually is we
did see it work with one of the white
walkers and the whites that he raised
but that doesn't mean it will work with
the knight king jon snow did not seem so
sure about that because when beric
Dondarrion said this Jon Snow said you
don't understand which implies it's not
going to be that easy
[Music]
he turned them all
you don't this time so that probably
means the night king will have an ace up
his sleeve or that might even be some
foreshadowing for the big twist at the
end of the series
either way this area needs to die for
good he is too big of a threat now
before I talk about Jaime Lannister let
me go over some of the possible ways
miss Ariane could die there are only a
handful of weapons that we know of that
can stop the night king soldiers but the
million-dollar question is which of
these weapons will work against Masseria
now that he's an undead dragon the first
method I want to discuss his fire
because it obviously plays a big part in
this entire series considering it was
adapted from a story that has the
overall title a Song of Ice and Fire
we know for a fact that fire can kill
White's this was the very first weakness
that Jon discovered back in season 1
when he caught the white on fire that
was attacking Lord Commander Mormont the
only problem is we don't know if fire
can kill the White Walkers of the night
King based on what we've seen so far it
doesn't seem to have much of an effect
on the night king or his top lieutenants
we saw the white Walker come right
through the fire at hardhome
not only did he walk through it but the
fire actually got smaller most likely
because of how cold the white Walker was
we saw this happen again right outside
of the three-eyed Ravens cave when the
night King led the assault on the cave
the children of the forest tried to
prevent them from entering by using fire
as a last resort this prevented the
whites from coming through the front of
the cave but it did not stop the night
king or the White Walkers and once again
the fire got smaller as they walked
through it which basically indicates
that it doesn't hurt them now I know
what some of you may be thinking what
about dragon fire dragon fire has
magical properties so it should work
against the White Walkers and the night
king but this hasn't been confirmed
either when Daenerys wouldn't be on the
wall with her dragons we only saw her
burning White's the White Walkers and
the knight King never came under direct
dragon fire so I don't know if it will
kill them or not the night king also did
something very interesting right before
he killed Masari on as the night king
prepared to launch his ice spear he
walked right through the dragon fire
that was on the ground and once again
the fire got smaller as he did this the
night king and the White Walkers never
showed an ounce of fear either Daenerys
had three dragons raining down fire on
his army in the night King never
flinched so dragons might not be enough
to stop him and this leads me to Vasari
on canvas Ariane be killed by fire
well if fire doesn't harm the night king
or the White Walkers then it probably
won't harm Vasari on either plus you
have to consider the fact that Viserion
is a dragon and dragons don't typically
die by fire dragons are actually fire
made flesh but what they still apply to
miss Ariane now that he's undead this is
a tough question to answer because we
don't know enough about his powers or
weaknesses yet if Viserion can be killed
by fire there is only one way I can see
this happening but I will save my answer
for the end of the video now let's move
on to the next weapon which is dragging
glass this weapon is a little more
effective because we have seen it kill
White's
and White Walkers dragonglass does not
actually kill White's in the books but
it does in the show since White's and
White Walkers can be killed by
dragonglass
then there is a good chance of that
vissarion can be killed by dragonglass
as well but I do need to point out there
are two things that could pose as a
problem for one dragon glass is very
brittle hence the word glass in the name
dragon glass can break just like glass
and Dragons have very tough skin I'm not
even sure if you would call it skin
because it's more like scales that are
thicker than leather we have seen arrows
bounce right off a drug on during the
field of fire so if they try and shoot
dragon glass adversary on it might just
explode into pieces on impact now
obviously there is no way to know unless
we see them try it but it would probably
break before it would pierce the dragon
scales using an arrow that has a tip
made out of dragon glass would be
nowhere near as strong as a tip made out
of some kind of steel or iron the second
problem is that most of the magical
properties in dragon glass come from
dragon fire dragon glass is actually
called frozen dragon fire since it is
made by a dragon's flame a
might not have an effect on Viserion
since he is of course a dragon albeit an
undead dragon so even though dragonglass
can kill a white or white Walker it
might not be able to kill a dragon now
the good thing is they do have a lot of
dragonglass john was able to mind the
Kazon dragon stone so I am assuming he
was able to get several tons this is
good because now he can arm pretty much
everyone with the weapon that can take
down almost anything in front of them
not only that but this will allow them
to take multiple shots at vissarion
without having to worry about running
out of projectiles the more shots you
are able to take the better chance you
have of taking him down
now even though dragon glass is very
brittle there is still one way you could
hurt maseri on and possibly even kill
him one way to kill a dragon is to shoot
something or plunge something into its
eye when vissarion has his eyes open
they are extremely vulnerable because he
has nothing to protect them but it's
obviously very hard to have that kind of
accuracy dragons are already very fast
but after Viserion was raised by the
knight king he seemed to be even faster
than before
so I don't know how they're going to be
able to get something into its eye
unless they are very lucky and this is
where Jaime Lannister could come into
play as we all know Jaime has tried to
kill a dragon before and he came pretty
damn close to being successful if for
some reason the knight King what
happened to laying vissarion on the
ground
Jaime might try to seize that as an
opportunity by going after a dragon
again now I'm not saying this will
happen this is not my actual prediction
but it's just another possibility I want
to discuss because if the arrows or
ballistas aren't working they might find
themselves in a desperate situation
Jaime does have a Valyrian steel sword
and this can kill White's and White
Walkers in the show so it should work
against Vasari on - or Jaime could also
use a dragon glass spear we know the
unsullied carry Spears and they will be
turning them into dragon glass spears
now that they're gonna be facing an army
of the Dead if the knight king landed
Vasari on for whatever reason someone
might have to take a charge at him and
pray they can jam one of the weapons
into his eye otherwise they may be
screwed
I have always felt that Jamie would
probably sacrifice himself while trying
to save one of the Starks Jamie's story
has been linked to brain stark ever
since the beginning of the story also
when lady Catelyn freed Jaime Lannister
he had a promise that in return he would
see that her daughters were given safety
which led Jaime to giving Brienne oath
keeper and sending her out to find them
now that there are only six episodes
left Jaime's Redemption arc will be
coming to an end very soon and with his
final act he might save at least one of
the Starks lives in order to do this he
may have to pay the ultimate price by
giving his life to save one of theirs
Jaime's empty pages in the white book
have haunted him for a very long time he
does not want to only be remembered as
the Kingslayer I think his final deed
will be remembered but it will cost him
his life imagine if Jaime put his life
on the line by attempting to kill Vasari
on before the dragon can completely burn
down Winterfell and anyone that is
inside the castle
now if Jaime doesn't happen to do it
then perhaps bran could kill Viserion I
haven't seen any ballistas in the north
but if they were able to supply them
then bran should definitely be one of
the people who main it we just have to
hope Jamie finds bran before he gets too
far north although I do believe Jaime
will find him and bring him since bran
and Jaime both tried to kill a dragon in
season seven I figured I should at least
mention them because they could always
try to do it again but there are a few
other ways vissarion could be killed
like I said at the beginning of the
video when Vissarion was killed I
released a video about ten minutes after
that episode ended in one of the other
ways I said he could die is by weirwood
arrows some of you might not know this
but there was a character named Brandon
snow and he was the bastard brother of
Torrance stark even if you haven't read
the books you might remember the name
Torrance stark because he was referenced
during season seven Torrance stark was
known as the king who knelt he bent the
knee to Aegon Targaryen when he arrived
with his three dragons now this is
interesting because Daenerys arrived
with her three dragons and John Snow was
the king in the north who bent the knee
just like Torrance stark did and just
like Torrance stark
also has a brother named Brandon well
before Turin Starck bent the knee
Brandon told him he would sneak into a
goons camp and kill his three dragons
but Turin stork ended up bending the
knee the very next day so we never found
out how Brandon was actually going to
pull this off but in a dance with
dragons bran stark has a vision and he
sees a man making arrows out of a
weirwood tree and can you guess how many
arrows he was making he was making three
arrows because they'd gone had three
dragons
so arrows made out of a magical weirwood
tree could probably kill a dragon
since george RR martin put these little
details in his story history tends to
repeat itself in this story a lot but it
usually plays out a little bit
differently when it does if Jon Snow is
the modern-day Turin Stark who was the
king in the north that bent the knee
then maybe brain stark is the modern-day
Brandon Snow who will try to kill a
dragon with weirwood arrows
no one knows a weirwood cherie better
than brain stark so it would make sense
if he would be the one to suggest
something like this but it would also
make sense if Bryan took the shot
himself we have seen bran practicing
with bow and arrow ever since the very
first episode of the series Bryan was in
the yard with John and Rob
but he kept missing his shot and they
all laughed at him then in season 3
brain even had a dream where he was
shooting his bow and John and Rob were
next to him again Bryan tried to shoot
the three-eyed Raven and he missed which
caused a John and Rob to laugh at him
again that would be pretty damn cool if
Bryan was actually the one to bring down
a dragon with his bow however I might
have to stick with my original
prediction I still tend to believe that
dragon will actually kill this Ariane
I mostly based this on the symbolism in
the dragon's names drogon was named
after called Drogo and Viserion was
named after Danny's brother Viserys
called Drogo killed by series when he
poured molten gold onto his head so I
think Joe gon will kill Viserion
and he may even do it in a similar
fashion by unleashing fire on his head
that's if dragon fire can even kill an
undead dragon and I'm not so sure if it
can but Drogo on could severe
in Gervais Arion to the point that it
slows him down enough for someone to get
off a shot or force him to land then
someone can take a charge at him either
way I think drogon will play a big part
in bringing down Vasari on
but that's just my opinion obviously
this could play out many different ways
and we don't know enough about this
dragons weaknesses to say which method
is right and which methods are wrong but
until we find out we can have some fun
by speculating on these things let me
know what you think about this topic how
do you believe vissarion will die put
your thoughts down below in the comment
section I want to thank you all for
watching the video I really appreciate
that and I also want to thank all of my
patreon supporters have a great day
everyone I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]